very pleased to see the new health
secretary sergeant javid joins us on the
program mr javid
very good morning to you and of course
congratulations on your return to good
morning but
but what a job you have to do and i i
want to start if we can with perhaps
one of the measures which has caused a
little bit of debate
as announced by the prime minister
yesterday face masks
yes or no are face masks effective in
reducing transmission of covet 19.
well now if i can explain we need to
learn to live
with the virus and that is why yesterday
i set out how we plan to ease
restrictions from july the 19th
providing the tests that we've said are
met
and the reason we can afford to do this
which
is to move from a system of rules and
regulations including
rules we currently have on face masks to
a system of
guidance and personal responsibility is
because
of the vaccine either vaccine is is
working it is uh
our wall of protection your jab by jab
brick by brig it has provided us with
this protection
which means that although case numbers
are high as i said yesterday i expect
them to go
far higher what we are seeing is a
severe
weakening of the link between case
numbers and hospitalization
and deaths and that is what is allowing
us to ease the restrictions
in this way so to turn to your question
about face masks that's what's why we
can
make this change and and move to a
system of guidance
but as you say it has severely reduced
the link between
infection and death but it hasn't broken
it and it follows of course
that if we are going to see as you just
put it a very significant rise in
infections
there will be a concomitant rise in
death so so again the question i did ask
was
are face mass effective at restricting
the transmission of covid19 and if so
why are we stopping people wearing them
now
well we've in terms of coming to the
decisions that were announced yesterday
by myself and the prime minister
of course we've taken the best possible
public health advice
scientific advice we have the best
advisors in the world
and and together looking at the impact
of the vaccine and the severe weakening
of that link
we of course are very comfortable with
the decisions
that were announced now i fully
understand why many people
will be anxious they'd want to be
cautious and that is why
other protections remain in place but
the the vaccines
are working and if i can just quickly
just share an example of
why i'm saying that is that you're at
the moment here in the last 24 hours
we're getting case numbers around over
25 000
a day but when you look at
hospitalizations
and deaths your deaths for example are 1
30th of what they were the last time we
saw
case numbers of that type and and also
when we're thinking about our health
challenges and health problems
one of the things i tried to set out
yesterday as well is as health secretary
i'm also
very concerned about all the non-covered
health problems which you know they
haven't gone away
and if anything they've got a lot worse
you know the waiting list
has grown dramatically it's going to
grow a lot more before it comes back
down again
sadly there are many people that have
not come forward
with cancer problems with heart disease
problems with mental health problems
and i'm very concerned about that too
minister i i completely i completely
understand that i'm not going to ask the
question again whether or not face masks
are affected because we know that they
are
in the latest meta-analysis that came
out in the last 24 hours six million
individuals involved in it
shows that it reduces transmission by
the very least 25 percent
so i'm just wondering about the the
shift that we have seen between
last thursday and yesterday evening in
which you know we're not being told what
to do anymore we've been given
personal responsibility to to make our
own decisions
on that basis in which circumstances
will you be wearing a mask
i always uh for the foreseeable future i
will be carrying a face mask with me i
think that's a very
responsible thing for anyone to do as
i've said the pandemic is
is not over and uh if i'm in a crowded
or enclosed space i will wear a face
mask
i'll wear one if i was next to someone
near someone that felt
uncomfortable with others not wearing
face masks that's the point and that's
what i mean by personal responsibility
yep but but also we learned this morning
from the papers and tried to stood it up
myself i mean government advisors have
been briefing out this
morning that vulnerable people who may
well be concerned about traveling on
public transport given that many people
choose not to wear a mask you've given
them the opportunity to do so
the advice from government for
vulnerable people people with maybe
suppressed immune systems and so on
is to travel outside peak times so we're
telling people who perhaps have received
a cancer diagnosis
that they will have to take a bus at
five o'clock in the morning that's what
this government means by personal
responsibility
well i i've given an example of when i
would wear a face mask and i hope other
people
will do similar but again to turn to
your particular question on face masks
why can we move
from a system of rules and regulation to
guidance and personal responsibility
it is because of the vaccine i mean the
vaccine is is working and
and the fact that now we've got the most
successful vaccine rollout
program in the world thanks to the nhs
and our scientists
you know what we have is a situation
where i think some four-fifths
of adults have had at least one jabs and
three
fifths have had two jabs and we've
announced recently our plans for a
booster program in september
and the purpose of these vaccines is so
that we can slowly
start taking our freedoms back you know
people do want to see
a return to something that looks more
like normal of course there are still
other protections in place for example
the border controls
we're going to have a more proportionate
and balanced test and trace system
and so there are other things that will
continue
to protect us but the most important
thing is the vaccine and i would urge
everyone to make sure that they're
jabbed up
strangely enough i'm off for my second
job later on today so the advice is well
taken
but but just in terms of that thank you
i i suspect i might need it getting up
at half past two tomorrow morning
but just in terms though of of of where
we go next i mean
you yourself have conceded there will be
additional deaths increased infections
means increased death i'm wondering if
we can get a figure
what would be an acceptable excess
mortality rate from covert 19 as we move
forward
it is i have to it's not about you know
something
some number and that's being acceptable
of course not you know what what we are
seeing is that with rising case numbers
and yesterday
i said we could see a doubling of case
numbers by the time we get to
july the 19th we are not seeing a
corresponding increase in
hospitalizations
and and death numbers and that is
because the vaccine's working that's
what the vaccines
for and we can't live in a world where
the only thing that we're thinking about
is covid and not about all the other
health problems not about our economic
problems our educational challenges
and we have to make use of a vaccine
that is thankfully
working and and and be aware of all the
other health problems
i've just mentioned a moment ago but as
health secretary i tell you when i came
into this department with a fresh set of
eyes
it is shocking when you look at all the
other health problems that have built up
some seven million people have not come
forward during the pandemic for help
from the nhs
with their health problems seven million
people now just think about
all the health problems that have been
stored up and
and we need to treat that as a priority
too it cannot just be about covid
sure indeed and as you mentioned the
fresh pair of eyes that you bring to it
i mean
it has to be said your approach this
that which we heard from you yesterday
and the prime minister is is a country
mile away from
from what we were hearing from from the
previous health sector you have to
consider it is a different approach and
that frankly
if matt hancock had remained in post we
probably wouldn't have had an
announcement of the type
we had yesterday so i'm just wondering
what has changed i mean the sage advice
has remained the same between thursday
and today
the you know the advice in terms of the
the data set
has all been going in exactly the same
direction to my mind the only thing that
has changed
is that we all had to swallow a gallon
of mind bleach after we all got to see
the former health secretary grabbing his
aides backside i mean
where is the science that has led us to
making this
fairly fundamental change in approach
i think what's changed since this
pandemic is
obviously we've learned a lot more about
the virus itself and
i've said a lot about the vaccine but
also it's worth mentioning the
treatments are
much much better than they were at the
start of this year one of my first
visits i think on my
second day on the job was to saint
thomas's hospital
and uh and i went to the see the doctors
and the consultants in the wards where
they
were previously treating hundreds of
cobit patients
and now they're at this the time i went
there are hardly any but what they
also explained to me was the impact of
the drugs the treatment
uh that was now available especially
dexmethazone
and that's important too so that's
something that's changed
since the pandemic but most of all
what's changed and again
i have to come back to the it is the
vaccines they are working and it is
allowing us
uh to take the measures that we
announced but let me say again
i absolutely can understand that many
people
uh will be will be cautious they'll be
anxious they'll be concerned i
absolutely i get that the prime minister
does my colleagues
throughout government do but we have to
take advantage
of the of the vaccines and the
protection they're providing how they
have severely weakened the link between
cases
and hospitalization and uh no one's uh
pretending here that
that there's a the this is all happened
before somewhere
and and and there's a risk-free way uh
out of this
uh we haven't pretended uh the
pandemics here they've been very
different um and so we have to
learn as we're going along but we're
getting the very best advice that there
is available
in the world from the best scientists in
the world and together with their advice
we're moving ahead do you understand why
some people found it curious to hear the
prime minister
you know speaking from downing street
yesterday lecturing us all not to be d
mob happy
on something that this government has
become very fond of describing his
freedom day
um i didn't quite get the question i'm
sorry you cut off
sorry i'll i'll repeat it do you
understand why some people finally get
curious
that the prime minister told us all
yesterday not to
be d mob happy to go wild to enjoy
ourselves too much
on something the successive government
ministers have been happy to describe as
freedom day
no i i think that what the prime
minister is is reflecting there is that
still advising people uh to take notice
of the guidance and
and and to emphasize that we expect
and hope people will show personal
responsibility and i know people will if
you look at the
the huge efforts that the british people
have made during the course of this
pandemic
obviously not just following rules but
just you know taking a more common sense
approach to
social interaction uh for example you
know that is what
i think will continue and i think that's
what the prime minister is emphasizing
that's
something that we'd all like to see just
in terms of
what might happen later on in the year
we heard of course from chris whitty the
prime minister and yourself
i've all said that winter may be
difficult it may be difficult for the
health service
on that basis can we just be absolutely
crystal clear
the government retains the power to
reintroduce
restrictions later in the year if
necessary if
as i'm sure you would say absolutely
necessary
the one one concern that is uh still
there and this is
throughout the world is that there will
be new variants i think
no one can rule out there won't be
further uh variants of
of covid and no one will know what they
will look like
there is a risk and i think it's a real
risk of some kind of vaccine resistant
variant there's no sign of that yet
anywhere but but
i think it's something that no one can
rule out and that is why
it's sensible to retain some powers and
one of the things i said yesterday for
example that local authorities
will retain their powers at least until
the end of september and before that
date we will
review them again so if there's a need
for the local use of powers you know
that that is something
uh that can be done uh promptly and so
it's it's important i think to to remain
cautious
in that way it's why we will also retain
uh border controls
uh your viewers will be familiar with
the so-called sort of traffic light
system
that will stay in place there may be
some proportion changes
to that i think the transport secretary
has already said
that we can soon afford to treat people
that are double vaccinated traveling
to amber countries differently but that
will also provide a degree of protection
and then also
there'll be a more proportioned and
balanced test and trace system
so i think all of these uh taken
together uh
are there to continue to protect us
especially against the emergence
of a new variant but at all times we of
course keep this under review